welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is James Levinson the Charles W Goodyear
professor in global affairs and
professor of economics and management
and the founding director of the Jackson
Institute for global affairs at Yale
University as the Jackson Institute's
first director professor Levinson brings
a wealth of international experience to
that post his fields of interest include
international economics industrial
organization economic development and
applied econometrics recently he has
studied the impact of hiv/aids on
unemployment and school attendance in
South Africa
professor Levinson has lived and worked
in Senegal Botswana and South Africa one
of his projects now in its 11th year
trans government officials University
faculty and students and NGO staff from
over a dozen countries in South Africa
on how to use data to inform
policymaking today we'll talk with
Professor Levinson about the new Jackson
Institute for global affairs
welcome professor Levinson pleased to be
here the Jackson Institute just opened
its doors a month ago in September
congratulations right let's talk a
little bit about it and its mission so
we really have three missions they're
all interrelated
our first task if you will is that we
are the home of the undergraduate major
International Studies and the master's
degree in international relations those
two degree programs are the focus of our
teaching we also offer courses that are
open to all students in Yale College so
we have some service courses as well as
courses for our majors the second thing
that we've really focused on is bringing
practitioners there senior fellows at
the Jackson Institute these are very
distinguished
people who have had careers in global
affairs bringing them into the classroom
Yale is just chock-full of wonderful
speakers on any given afternoon and my
goal is to get people to come and to
engage not with an afternoon lecture but
teaching an entire semester or at least
several weeks and we have a number of
these Jackson fellows who are currently
on campus and teaching courses okay I'm
sorry no no the third thing that we
focused on I mentioned there were three
is offering career services to Yale
students but with a special focus on
students who are interested in what you
might think of as non-traditional or non
business oriented careers abroad careers
in diplomacy careers in the State
Department careers in government careers
with NGOs so we have that office up and
running also very good let's talk a
little bit about the first part of you
know the students and and the classwork
your training students basically to be
future leaders how are you going about
doing that we're doing that by trying to
give them the tools they need in a world
that we don't really know what it would
look like so we're trying to give them a
tool box trying to teach courses that
use economics that use political science
courses that draw on the experiences of
the Jackson fellows so that they will be
able to succeed in a pretty agile way
and respond to a marketplace that quite
honestly I have no idea what it will
look like five ten years from now the
senior fellows as you mentioned are
heavy hitters one of them I know is
General Stanley McChrystal tell us a
little bit more about the fellows and
specifically and how you chose them so
we have a wide range and we wanted to
get a group of senior fellows who were
quite obviously distinguished but bring
different things to the table so you
mentioned general McChrystal Stan
McChrystal is teaching seminar on
leadership something he's very very well
qualified to do I've sat in on the first
class or two it's fascinating
just fascinating about 20 students a mix
of mostly graduate students but we saved
about six or seven slots for
undergraduates so he speaks on issues of
leadership and he has a group of people
coming in talking about leadership what
what makes for an effective leader
leadership in an age of 24/7 media
coverage he has a fascinating syllabus
some of the other ones some of the
others so what we have Steve Roach Steve
is a former president or chairman of
Morgan Stanley Asia in the world of Wall
Street economists he's a rock star Steve
is teaching a course titled the next
China most of our courses we expected to
have maybe if we were lucky 50 60
students I think Steve has something
like 200 250 students and he's dry on
his experiences both as an economist and
as a business person who's been working
in Asia for the last many years also on
the economic side Rakesh Mohan is senior
fellow Rakesh was the deputy governor of
the Reserve Bank of India
sometimes when I'm describing this to
friends I just say well he's the Ben
Bernanke of India he is it's really fun
to have an economist teaching a course
not so much drawing on a textbook
although Rakesh as a distinguished PhD
economists but he's also the guy who
helps set interest rates for 1.2 billion
people thought about these things okay
so you have China covered India covered
what about the Middle East Middle East
is fascinating we're thrilled to have
Marwan MA sure as a senior fellow Marwan
is the former deputy president of Jordan
he was Jordans first ambassador to
Israel and former Jordanian ambassador
to the United States he's doing a course
on Middle East peace has a wonderful
simulation exercise it's a great class
your experience your extensive
experience out in the world I'm sure is
going to be influencing
what you do at the Jackson Institute how
how are you bringing your personal
experiences in terms of shaping how the
Jackson Institute grows so I'm actually
gonna try to not bring my personal
experiences at least too heavily to bear
I'm only one person and there are many
different and fascinating career paths
I've done a fair amount of work in
developing countries and that will be
one of the areas of focus for the
Jackson Institute I've been recently
working in the field of global health as
well as economics and we will be
offering a number of courses in in that
field I think there's a lot of interest
and a lot of expertise on this campus in
the field of global health we there's
wonder they're wonderful programs at the
graduate level but undergraduates
haven't traditionally had as much ask as
much access to those courses to that
field yet the interest is there so we'll
be adding courses in global health
courses in economic development courses
in development more broadly what are the
institutions required for countries to
thrive but for example I have virtually
no experience in the world of diplomacy
yet that's one of the areas of focus of
the Jackson Institute we have multiple
diplomats who are coming or are in
residence and I think that'll be fun too
wonderful and you are teaching a course
for undergraduates that I hear is very
popular gateway to global affairs tell
us a little bit about it I understand
there's four parts to it and I'm
wondering how how you chose the themes
for the class so this class is fun it's
we've chosen as you noted four topics
the first topic was u.s. immigration
policy what should immigration policy be
what are some of the forces that come to
play in thinking about the politics as
well as the economics of it and for that
module I think of these four topics as
comprising modules of the course for
that module Gordon Hanson an expert on
immigration policy from the University
of California San Diego came and joined
me
I taught the part on globalization he
taught the part on immigration was fun
we have about 200 students in this class
mostly freshmen and sophomores it's fun
to teach a class where last spring most
of these kids were in high school
I love the being able to bring global
affairs to a new audience what about the
other three
the other three segments sure so you
have the the second segments ongoing
right now it's on US energy policy and
gnash use me energy policy and national
security and we have Jim Woolsey the
former director of the CIA under
President Clinton teaching that he's
great he was a courtroom attorney for 22
years prior to some of his other many
jobs and he's been fascinating the third
module leaves the United States
altogether and will look at policy
around hiv/aids in sub-saharan Africa
professor Nicola Nattrass from the
University of Cape Town will teach that
module and then the last module will be
Richard Goldstone mr. Goldstone is the
author of the so-called Goldstone report
on the US excuse me on the conflict in
Gaza he's also known perhaps less
perhaps less well known but equally
important he was the chief prosecutor
for the Rwandan and the Bosnian genocide
trials and he'll be doing a module on
the role of international law
wonderful how where do you see the the
Jackson Institute in the next ten years
what are your aspirations for it
Wow Marilyn so we've been open for two
and a half weeks we got a spot ten years
feels like a while I would love to have
just an incredible undergraduate major
it's well established and that is
drawing great Yale college students who
are going to go on and really impact the
world around them and it's a major I
think that will equip them to do exactly
that I'd like to have a world class
masters degree program and I'd like to
continue I think
we're off to a great start with our
Jackson senior fellows I want to keep
that rolling thank you so much for being
here with us today oh it's my pleasure
thank you so much for more information
about Professor Levinson and the Jackson
Institute please visit our website at
yale.edu backslash McMillan report be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the McMillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty McMillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you